son el símbolo del apoyo francés a
ucrania los obuses autopropulsados sobre
los campos elíseos un desfile del 14 de
julio marcado por la actualidad
liderando el cortejo los uniformes
coloridos atraen toda la atención los
portaestandartes de los aliados del este
europeo bulgaria estonia rumanía y
hungría invitados de honor saludados por
la multitud
estoy orgullosa de que estén aquí y que
sepan que francia está con ellos
es un símbolo fuerte para mostrar a
vladimir putin que tiene que detener
esta guerra inútil entre los asistentes
familiares y amigos de los soldados que
quieren verlos desfilar pasan dos
minutos
tiempo de ver como la patrulla de
francia dibuja la bandera en el cielo de
parís
míralo escoltadas por caza rafale las
fuerzas de disuasión aérea como el agua
que un avión de alerta temprana y
control aerotransportado
el hijo de esta pareja de bretaña lo
pilota
si es genial
otros buscan altura o encuentran métodos
creativos para no perderse ni un segundo
de la acción uno por uno distintos
regimientos del ejército desfilan
defienden nuestro país así que pienso
que tenemos que estar aquí también es el
más guapo es el más radiante no se
preocupen por nosotras lo veremos
enseguida uno por uno distintos
regimientos del ejército desfilan
4.925 mujeres y hombres marcharon a pie
bajo la mirada del presidente de manuel
macrón el dron reaper sobrevuela la
capital por primera vez tras ser usado
por las fuerzas francesas en el sahel en
la lucha contra los grupos yihadistas
sin embargo el mayor aplauso del día fue
para los bomberos
[Música]
la ceremonia terminó con los atletas con
la presencia de los medallistas
olímpicos de tokio a la espera de las
próximas medallas que se repartirán
dentro de dos años en parís